Dans "pourquoi on dit",
je vous raconte cequi se cache
derrière les expressions de la langue française.
Alors abonnez-vous
et n'oubliez pas...
que je suis cloche...
Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
pourquoi dit-on:
"passer du coq à l'âne"
Cette expression signifie changer de sujet ou
d'idées sans transition ou sans suite logique,
ce que nous allons éviter justement
pour comprendred'où vient cette expression.
Mais pourquoi le "coq" et "l'âne" ?
En fait l'âne, il ne s'agit probablement pas
à l'origine du cousin du cheval.
L'âne qui s'écrit avec un accent
circonflexe sur le "a"
mais plutôtde l'âne
sans chapeau sur la première lettre,
un mot qui au Moyen-Âge désignait la cane,
la femelledu canard.
Pas celle sur laquelle on s'appuie.
L'expression devait donc s'entendre plutôt comme
sauter du coq à la cane.
D'un animal à l'autre qu'ils n'avaient rien à voir.
Il s'agissait aussiparfois de se moquer du coq
qui pouvait aller jusqu'à courtiser la cane
qui n'a rien à voir
évidemment avec la poule.
Avec le temps le mot "asne" désignant la cane
a disparu
mais l'expression
"passer du coq à l'âne" est resté,
"âne" s'écrivant avec un accent circonflexe
comme le mot désignant le
cousin aux grandes oreilles du cheval.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à laisserun pouce bleu.
Merci les Épicurieux !
Pour les plus gourmands en voici d'autres et pour ne
rien rater abonnez-vous et activer la cloche.